So why would I have you enter all those numbers for long division? Are we only
concerned about the answer? Well, no. Math is about reasoning and we can use
that reasoning in new situations like here. We'll use our understanding of
dividing numbers to divide polynomials. To divide x plus 5 into x squared plus 7
x plus 10, we're going to start with these first two terms. I want to think
about the expression that I could put here to multiply by x to get x squared. In
other words, I'm taking x squared and dividing it by x. That variable must be x.
Next, we multiply x by x and positive 5, and we get x squared plus 5x . This
step was very similar to multiplying 2 times 4 to get the 8. Now that we're
here, we want to subtract. So I want to subtract this entire amount or
expression. This is really a negative 1 times each of these quantities. So we
want to make sure that we change both of the signs. When I subtract the amount
I'll have negative x squared and negative 5x. Both of the signs change. X
squared minus x squared equals 0, and 7x minus 5x equals 2x. Next we bring down
the ten to continue the next step of our long division problem. Now I want you
to try that same process again. You're going to divide x plus 5 into 2x plus 10.
What number would go here? And then when you multiply this number by x plus 5,
what two expressions do you get here? Then you're going to subtract this
quantity, and put in your final answers down here.